Hi everyone. Welcome to today's event. My name is Danushi Vijayakula Surya. I'm a data
scientist at Microsoft and I will be your moderator today and I will also share a bit
about myself later as a speaker. And so we have several speakers today who will share
about navigating massive layoffs and hiring freezers and careers in the tech industry.
So with that, Bernard, do you want to share about yourself?
Bernard, yes.
Yes, I think it would help if I unmuted my screen. So I need to do this. Okay. Share this. All right.
So you see my screen, right? Does everybody see my screen?
Yes.
All right. Excellent. So my name is Bernard. I have a doctorate in agriculture and applied
economics. I went to the University of Georgia. I've been in the finance industry for over 20
years. I've worked with multiple companies from American Express to JP Morgan Chase and I've been
here at Wells Fargo for about three and a half years. I focus on, I mean, the corporate risk
model oversight model, the corporate model risk team. We focus on validating models where we test
them for conceptual soundness, for resilience, for reliability and for robustness. It's been a fun
time. It's actually a great company to work for. I hope I'm going to stay here for a long time.
But I want to talk to you about the undergraduate and graduate opportunities that we have here in
Wells Fargo. If I may say so myself, this is the best in class in the finance industry. So here,
this document says university program, but this is really for people that are graduating from
school. Some are soon to graduate, others are far away. So we have different types of programs.
But once you come in, there are options for you to build a network. We have programs that help you
build a network while you learn about the Wells Fargo culture. You receive some intense training
about six weeks where after you join, you're housed in this program where there's an intense
training for quantitative skills, for business knowledge skills and stuff. But typically,
you also get a chance to participate in community event services. You engage with senior leaders.
You continue to get access to development and opportunities and alumni engagement opportunities
post your graduation. And then you also get exclusive events tailored specifically for
our recent graduates. The key thing here is we try to use this as an early talent recruitment
program. We want to be looking for people with quantitative skills, technical skills, people,
leadership, people, engagement skills, and communication skills. Those are some of the
key requisites that we generally seek when we are looking for candidates. And then obviously,
once you come in, we'll help you expand your skills. So in Wells Fargo, like I said, we have
the quantitative analytics program, which is really aimed at people who are about to graduate. So by
the time they get in here, they should have graduated. And then we have the internship
program for people that are a few months or a few years away from graduation. But in Wells Fargo,
we have seven centers of excellence, right? And each of them is tailored to specific areas. So
going from left to right of the screen, the first four areas are really tailored to specific lines
of business. So it spans from corporate and investment banking to consumer and small business
banking, wealth and investment management and commercial banking. In here, the centers of
excellence are focused on providing quantitative solutions to address specific business needs.
And then as you pan to the last three, these are more enterprise-wise. So they are not specific to
any of these segments that we talked about, these four segments. They do stuff here. We do stuff that's
agnostic of these. So within here, for instance, you have the corporate model risk. This is the
team organization, which I said, where we validate a lot of models. And I'll talk to you
about some of the day in life of a modeler in a few minutes. But here's the value. We do a lot
of validation and governance work in this team. The risk modeling team also provides some analytics
to support specific areas in and across these lines of business. You have the market and
counterparty risk analytics. You have this finance team, this finance center of excellence
that focuses on more good model development. And then we have the AI center of excellence.
Do you still see my screen or did I stop sharing? We can't see your slides.
I'm sorry. Yeah. Apologies. And then you have the artificial intelligence and machine learning
center of excellence. I'm sure a lot of folks will find this one. I'll use this as a day in the life.
So the day in the life. So again, key thing is we have seven centers of excellence
where you have people embedded within the centers of excellence to support specific needs of the
area. Again, four of these are targeted towards specific segments. And then these three are
enterprise wide. So I'll scroll down to one of these ones as an example of day in the life.
I'm sorry. Somebody want to say something? Can you put your view on the full screen?
It is Randy. Is that it? No, it was correct before.
Okay. So is this okay? Perfect. Yes. Excellent. Okay. So I wanted to talk to
talk a little bit about the center of excellence for artificial learning and
machine learning and artificial intelligence. Yeah. So I wanted to focus on this because I
think most of the folks in this audience will be very interested in this, right? So here the center
of excellence, they focus on the response for developing models in support of any enterprise
function that utilizes AI methods and or NLP use cases. So NLP, natural language processing,
they focus on these. They focus on use cases such as a sanctions list screening, for instance.
That's where the area where, you know, you have a sanctions list, they're trying to make sure that,
you know, those folks on those entities on that list are captured and we prevent them from doing
business with the bank, right? And then this since it's all worldwide, it's international,
you have different, you know, the focus on attributes such as name, address and stuff.
And for names, you have to be keenly aware of the language so that you can transcribe or translate
or transliterate any of the names into the, you know, into the various sections that are various
formats that are with the sanctions that entities appear. You have some machine
learning techniques development that goes on for digital experience. So you have your virtual
assistance. You have cyber security and adversarial attacks that use machine learning
techniques to identify those. You have machine learning techniques that are used for models that
are used for the corporate, the COO office, you know, so this is more like data management across
enterprise, payment transformation, business continuity, resiliency, resilience, conduct
surveillance, et cetera. And then you also have this thing where this area where, you know, there's
refresh, constant refresh for model implementation, monitoring, et cetera. And these are cuts across
all the enterprise. Again, this is focused on artificial learning, machine learning
methods, but for each of the series, like I said, there's specific work that goes on.
And, you know, while you're here, the idea is you are expected to work on machine learning projects
covering end-to-end model development. There's some agile methods for certain project squads.
You work with very multiple partners across LOB, technology governments, you name it. We use all
sorts of, you know, techniques here. So the transambles, regression, CNN. We use tool in Python,
HPO, and Spark. Right. And then, like I said, we also have, we have certain resources, you know,
so these links are available. But the key thing is for the QAP program, I don't know if it's not
on this deck, but we have this, it's an annual program that's been going on since 2012. And
usually starts, we start opening those programs around the September framework while we open the
applications specifically target to QAP, target focus on quantitative analytics program. And those
are usually focused on masters and PhD candidates who are expected to graduate by June next year.
So we take the applications around September. We take them through the interviews, multiple rounds
of interviews. They typically last through, by end of, through December. And then, you know,
this year, last year, we actually sent out, started sending out invitations, invitations from,
what do you call it, office by end of December. So the folks, you know, would have some
quant, tangible information in hand as they prepare to round up their,
their degree programs. And then, you know, by June, they're here. And then we take them through the
fellowship program for early quants. So I'll pause here, see if anybody has some questions
that they'd like to talk about, they'd like to ask.
I also remind people we have a Q&A session at the end. So
you can use the Q&A option here to pose your questions at that time.
If there are no questions right now, we can move on to Shannon Dong.
Thank you.
All right. So let's see. So my name is Shannon. I work at the Boeing Company. And I don't have,
I'm not a, you know, an HR person or anything like that. So I just, for full disclosure, I am
part of the engineering department. And so just a little bit of kind of
personal tips, if you will. So this is not on behalf of like the Boeing Company in any official
sense of the word. So just a few tips for like looking for jobs. So I guess maybe a little bit
of background. I actually have sort of more, I was planning to talk about background a little
bit later, but I am an associate tech fellow at Boeing. I run lots of projects, but I'm not a
manager. So I don't oversee people. I oversee projects. And kind of when I am choosing,
you know, engineers to work on my projects, what am I looking for when I am, you know,
looking for people? I think ultimately, these are the four things that are really important to
my project. So first, the ideal engineer would have, you know, all the right hard skills. And
the hard skills are, for us, it would be like CAD modeling or simulation work or hands-on hardware
development, software development, so things like that. And then they have to have
good communication skills. And I kind of think of that as like softer skills.
But really, it's almost as important as the hard skills to me. The ability to clearly communicate
through email or through just talking. And sometimes those skills are overlooked
for many engineers. So I say like, those are the type of things that are the big ones.
It takes a lot of initiative to work in a big corporation and to really stand out. I think that
when I, you know, assign projects to people, often I'm looking for those engineers that'll
take it on and run with it and not have to be handheld, you know. And so I think that's the
other part that I think is important. And then finally, the person has to be a nice person.
So it's interesting, when Boeing conducts interviews, I would say most of the questions
for engineering roles are going to be soft skill related. So they're going to be like,
how do you work together as a team? What kind of conflicts have you come across? How do you resolve
those types of conflicts? And when I was a student, I was thinking like, wow, like,
why do they care so much about, you know, these soft skills things? And I think it's actually
because Boeing produces airplanes, there is no way that one single person can build an airplane
by themselves. And so it is really, really important that people really work together
and that environment that they create together can make a lot of difference. You can really
make a break in a project. And so yeah, being a team player, I think it's really one of those
critical things. So I think when you are or if you are seeking a job, for example, at Boeing,
or really anywhere, these are the four things that just kind of, these are the things that
the other side will be looking for. And so you'll want to think about how to convey these qualities.
For Boeing, here are a few tips I have for job hunting. So obviously, our job website is
jobs.Boeing.com. And I've actually helped several friends, you know, like look for roles at Boeing.
And the way I do that is I actually go to the website and what you can do is you can filter by
the location. And typically, you know, if you don't want to move, you'll want to focus by that.
And then I actually just skim through the entire list. And the reason why I don't search for
anything more specific than that is because they often, like often the person searching will not
know which buzzwords to use. And yeah, it's kind of a painstaking process. But that's my tip. Like
I actually looked through the entire list. And then there are a few things to note, like there are
different engineering levels. So if you are looking for an engineering role, for example,
a role that says experienced engineers that does blah, blah, blah, you know, design engineers,
something like that. The words, you know, experience or senior or principal, like what those
kind of equate to are our engineering levels. And we have six engineering levels. So for example,
college, a bachelor degree would usually come in as a level one. And that would be an entry level.
A master's degree would typically come in as a level two. And then a PhD would typically
come in as a level three, or yeah, what would be called experience level. And then level four
would be a senior, usually that has some number of years with experience, etc. So those are
some things like when you're looking at the jobs listed at jobs.downt.com, you can look for
the appropriate, you know, level that is desired there. A few other things to note, we have several
different programs for hiring for entry points. There is one that's called EHI, which is early
accelerated hiring initiative, where we have partnerships with 27 universities that specialize
in engineering across the country. And they hold career for events on site, they do interviews,
potentially that same day, and then they give offers potentially like that same week,
or maybe even that same day. It's a very, very fast process. And in those cases,
they are not being hired for any particular role just yet, they get hired into a pool.
And that pool, then there's another process where they match the students with
an appropriate management team at Boeing. So that is, I think, a very nice, you know,
fast way to get a role, get a position at Boeing. But it is again, only available to those 27
engineering colleges. We do have a lot of internship opportunities. Those are again,
they will be listed at jobs.downt.com. And there's sort of a cycle of a year, I'm sure,
you know, that's probably true for most large companies as well. And then we also hold lots of
events, or I should say we participate in a lot of external affiliation events. So for example,
Society of Women Engineers holds a conference, or the Veterans Association, things like that.
So we will go to these events. And they will seem like we're just there to see how things are and
attend this conference. But just know that within Boeing, there will be management teams that are
actively seeking to interview people and recruit during those events. So that's another opportunity
available for people who are interested in that. Usually what happens is, let's say you submit
through jobs.downt.com, and then someone will reach out. And the next step in the process is
the interview process. Interviews have often been on the phone, or through, you know, through
WebEx. Well, we usually use WebEx, but maybe through Zoom. Or it could be, it could potentially,
I think it could potentially be on site. But I guess a few tips that I have for
the folks that I mentor, usually I would say review the common interview questions. And those
interview questions are going to be mostly the soft skill questions, as well as, you know, what kind of
project background the person has. So it's not, at Boeing, it won't be like other tech companies
where they'll like, you know, having to solve a problem on the spot. That's not very typical.
For us, I think it's more typical to ask more teaming type questions, more soft skill questions,
and then project questions. So based on your resume, what kind of projects have you worked on,
it is expected that that person really understands every aspect of their projects and can explain it.
I would say definitely practice. If you just Google or search online, you know,
common interview questions, and then you go through and say, all right, I can answer this,
this, this, this, like, this is how I'd answer all of them. So definitely practice that.
Some things that I think are less common, I would say,
have a build yourself a little cheat sheet. And I don't actually mean you would cheat with it. But
I think it helps. So here's a little example, right? I would say, you know, just list out all
the different projects that you've worked on, the major things that you want to showcase yourself.
So let's say you have, you know, all these different projects that you've worked on,
and then make another list on the side of common interview questions. So for example, you know,
what's your, have you ever met with a conflict and how did you resolve it? Or how did you process,
like, what's your, give an example of a failure and how did you handle that, right? So these are
common interview questions. And then you can just try to figure out, like, how to answer those
questions, and which, which projects they would point to. So if you were asked a question that
was failure handling, okay, which project are you going to use as the example on that question?
So just kind of, I would say it helps to list it out in advance to think through which,
which project you will use as the example. And in that case, when the time comes,
right, during an interview, you've already kind of reviewed that with yourself. And so when a
question comes up, even if it's not one of those questions that you listed, it's probably close
enough, right? And then you can immediately think of an appropriate project to talk about for that,
for that question. I think that really helps because otherwise some of, sometimes people
like to focus in on one project and they will answer all the questions based on that one project
and they will never showcase the other aspects of their experience. The other thing that I,
the other tip I give to my mentees is that you can bring, like, a show and tell piece. So
if it's a face-to-face interview, you can bring a little piece of hardware with you and show the
interviewer, you know, what you've worked on. You can bring, you can share a slide or a video
of some piece of, you know, technology you've worked on. Don't be afraid to make it real,
right? So that's another thing. And they won't necessarily be expecting that. So it would be kind
of a nice break for them. A little bit about Boeing. Boeing has four major branches. So there's
BCA, which is commercial airplanes. There's research in technology, defense,
and then global services, which is a little bit of a smaller piece. And I am under
Boeing commercial airplanes, which is mostly here in the Puget Sound area. Obviously there's a lot
of Boeing facilities all around. So when you are interviewing or when you're job hunting
or interested in Boeing, you kind of get a feel for where within the company you'd like to be.
And then a little point about kind of the track that we have at Boeing. For engineers,
we typically have two development tracks. One is obviously through management, where you are
overseeing a group of people, but not necessarily projects. And then the other is technical
leadership. And that is through our technical fellowship track. So in my case, I've gone with
the technical leadership track. And I kind of mentioned already that we have six engineering
levels. Yeah. So I think the topic of this panel was supposed to be on massive layoffs. And so I
wanted to kind of throw in there a little note about how we in the company, at least from what I
know, handle this. So every year we have a performance management process. In the beginning
of the year, we write out our business goals and objectives, I guess. And we list out kind of like
each of these projects that I'm working on. I plan to deliver whatever it is by the end of the year
or by whatever date. And they can be specific goals. They can be broad goals. They can even
be like, I plan to have zero safety instances this year or something like that. But generally
speaking, we list those out at the beginning of the year. And then at the end of the year,
there's a mid-year and then at the end of the year with our management team, we will sit down
and kind of review the performance. There's a little bit of strategy and how we define our goals
in the end of the year. But essentially, that's kind of a process. From the performance management
process, then we have these things called retention ratings for engineering roles. And
it's basically, you know, there's three levels, like rating one, two, or three. And if there were
a layoff going on, the layoff would basically siphon from the retention rating three. That's
typical of what goes on. Now, I think in 2020 and 2021, we had several rounds of
what we call VLOs and ILOs. So VLO is a voluntary layoff and an ILO is an involuntary layoff.
And typically, our VLOs and ILOs always have a kind of benefit. So there's an incentive.
And I think it's interesting, like VLOs, we've typically lost lots of experienced engineers,
people who have worked there for 34 years, and they're ready to retire essentially. And so they
take the VLO and it has a nice package. The ILOs typically are for the, I would say,
unfortunately, the newer engineers and folks with the lower retention ratings.
And that's typically been what I've observed. And again, like I am not part of HR, so this is
just my little view into this world here. But that's just, that's just a little bit of background
how that works. And I guess I would have to speak a little bit about how I came to this
role. I have a PhD in robotics and automation from MIT. And when I was graduating,
I really wasn't thinking of Boeing. It wasn't really top of my list. I was looking around at
SpaceX and other more, you know, in my mind, more exciting companies. And
I went through the hiring process and there was a manager that came and talked to me and said,
hey, like I need someone to develop these future factories for us. And I was like,
okay, that sounds interesting. But I guess ultimately there was a CTO at the time who
came and talked to the students and said, you know, Boeing is so large, it's so multifaceted,
that if you get bored in one place, you can easily move to a different team and work on
something completely different. It also is, you know, there are companies out there and I think
like he was implying, you know, companies like SpaceX that build rockets. And he said, well,
you know, we do that too. So if you are interested in that, you can also be part of that as well.
So there are just like lots of opportunities at Boeing and lots of different areas.
So I guess to me, I felt like, okay, well, I'll give it a try. And I've been there for a decade
now. So it's been an interesting ride. So I'm part of product development under Boeing commercial
airplanes. And we develop the airplanes of the future. So anything with a name on it, like 737
or 87, like those are not part of our purview. We are looking at airplanes that don't have names yet
and developing the production system for those airplanes for the future. I guess the,
oh, and I should probably mention here that through my time at Boeing and all of the
projects I work on, I've established several collaborations with the University of Washington.
And so I'm also an affiliate assistant professor there. And I run the Boeing Advanced Research
Center at the University of Washington. And I guess that's why it says that in the beginning of
the, yeah. So ultimately, I guess, if anybody has any questions about
applying for engineering roles, feel free to reach out. Thanks so much.
Thanks, Shannon. Yeah, feel free to put your questions in the Q&A. Martin, are you...
Yep. Just let me boot up here.
Alrighty. How is that looking?
Yep. That looks good.
Cool. All right. Wow. I've got to follow someone who actually builds airplanes. This is intimidating.
Boeing is such a cool company. And I was so sad that the last ever 747 took off from your
Washington factory there a few weeks ago, one of my all-time favorite planes.
So I'm Martin Tingley, and I'm extremely bad at following instructions in all forms. So
this is going to have a little bit of a different flavor. I want to talk a little bit about how I
ended up where I am at Netflix. I'll say a couple of words about what I do, and then I'll share
some personal reflections on... We'll go with non-linear career journeys, which I think is
particularly relevant at this moment, because this is a time when many of us need to think
a little bit more about deviating from paths we might have set for ourselves. And if you take
anything away from what I say today, take away that that's okay. If you have a plan and then
you do something else, that's just fine. So if we go back several decades, I ended up with a PhD
from Harvard in earth and planetary science with a master's degree in stats in about 2009.
And at that point in my life, I was 100% on a faculty path. It was like, I'm going to do
interdisciplinary research and statistical climatology. It's going to be awesome. The
NFF is going to throw money at me and we're going to do great work. Obviously something changed. So
let's talk a little bit about the steps. My work as a graduate student, as an academic, really
focused on using a lot of hierarchical bays modeling, time series modeling to understand
climate variability over hundreds to thousands, even millions of years, using things like old
thermometers, measurements on old trees, measurements from ice sheets, things like that. So just really
cool, I thought, high quality applied stats work in that climate and weather domain.
So after I graduated, I spent a year down in North Carolina at SAMHC right next door to NIST,
which is, I think, one of the reasons I know Jim Rosenberger. Again, still really on that faculty
path at that point, but if you remember what the world was like in about 2009, we were still coming
out of the financial crisis and much like right now, jobs were not easy to find.
I then spent a year over in Colorado at NCAR, the National Center for Atmospheric Research at
the Institute for Mathematics Applied to the Geosciences, which I always thought was like my
spiritual home as an academic. And at that point, I'd say I was like 90% on the faculty path. I
started having these existential questions. What am I? Am I a statistician? Well, the stats
departments I applied to don't seem to think so. Am I a climate scientist? Well, I don't think so.
I applied to don't seem to think so. Am I a climate scientist? Well, the sort of atmospheric
or earth and planetary science departments I applied to, they don't seem to think so.
Maybe this interdisciplinary research stuff has some downsides. That's the, I think, the best
office I'll ever have in my life. NCAR is located in this beautiful building designed by IM Pei,
right in the foothills of the Rockies. It was amazing. So then, again, unable to find a real
faculty job, I actually went back and worked for a few more years with my doctoral advisor at Harvard,
worked a lot with some of his grad students, enjoyed writing a whole ton of proposals that
were generally rejected. But, you know, if you put aside some struggles on the job market and
struggles with funding, it was a lot of fun. I was super productive, worked with some great people,
but really starting to think maybe this interdisciplinary research has its drawbacks.
So in 2013, I kind of landed this dream job, and that's definitely where I got to know Jim Rosenberger
at Penn State, because they were hiring, they had this amazing faculty hiring program where
you were hired like 51% into a science department and 49% into the stats department.
Just really a perfect fit for me from that academic perspective. But as sometimes happens
in life, once you get what you always want, you decide, well, maybe I don't want it after all.
And when I think about my time as a faculty member, what I always reflect on is I sort
of enjoyed every distinct element of that job and that time, but I didn't like the whole package.
There were also some personal challenges. My wife was back in Boston at the time, so we were doing
a lot of driving, and I wasn't getting enough sleep, and I was teaching actuarial science students,
and I kept thinking that if they knew how much I was driving on how little sleep, they would
probably suggest my life insurance premium should go up, and that didn't seem like a sustainable
thing. But the work itself, I really enjoyed. It's just that package wasn't quite what was
optimal for me and my family. So what do you do if you're faced with an optimization problem
and local perturbations don't really help? You try to jump to a new area of the parameter space.
So I started looking around for personal reasons. I have some connections in Australia,
and from 2015 to 2017, I worked at this company called Insurance Australia Group pricing natural
catastrophe risk for them. And it was a super cool and natural transition into the private sector
for me because I was still dealing with weather and climate data. We're still doing pretty cool
probabilistic modeling. We just put dollar signs at the end of all the work and say it was risk.
So from my perspective, it was a great opportunity to learn more about the private sector, about
for-profit businesses, new ways of framing problems, also new metrics for what success meant. Success
no longer meant writing a bunch of papers. It meant actually helping the company understand,
quantify, and quantify their risk and ultimately make some money.
But some things also stayed the same. Super interesting problems and super interesting
people are everywhere, particularly if you go seek them out. This is the best place I've ever
lived in my life. This is just south of Sydney, Australia. We lived like a 400-yard walk from the
beach. It was amazing. And then in 2017, I got one email from a Netflix recruiter. And sometimes
when opportunity knocks, you don't ask it to come back later. You just take the call and see what's
going to happen. So 2017, we moved back across the Pacific Ocean. And for the last six years,
I've been leading data science teams at Netflix focused on experimentation. It's been really a
period of massive personal and professional growth for me. It's certainly the best job I've
ever had in my life. And one thing I want you to know here is the best job, the best office,
and the best place to live, we're all separated by thousands of miles. And as you think about
navigating your own career at this pretty uncertain moment, be aware that joint optimization is really
hard. And maybe you'll have to think about what's most important to you. So a little bit about my
role at Netflix. We've actually written very extensively on this. So if you go to our tech
blog, you can read 10,000 words about what me and my team do. So I won't recite that. But I work
on our experimentation platform. And to understand what that means, let's go way back in time.
This is a picture of Rothamsted Research Station, where Ari Fisher developed most of the statistics
that many of us on this call use on a daily basis. And ultimately, this is an experimentation
platform. You take the land, you chop it up into bits, and you try different agricultural practices
on little plots of land. And then you do standard Fisherian inference to back out your treatment
effect and make a decision. But you can tell just from this plot, the throughput of experiments is
low. Experiments are going to take a long time to run, and the overall data volume is going to be
really small. At Netflix, we have at the moment over 200 million paying members. We have a very
complex UI. We have a huge diverse set of personalization algorithms running in the
background that really help you connect with the content that's best for you and allows that content
to speak to you in a way that will resonate. And we run A-B tests that Fisher would recognize
on every aspect of our product experience to try to improve it for our members. The real thing
that's different is the throughput of experiments, so how many we have going at a time, how quickly
we can execute on many of these experiments, and the data volume. So a lot of what me and my team
do, I talk about it's turning innovation into commodity. How can we take what's interesting
from the experimentation and causal inference literature and make that fast and accessible to
a broad swath of the company so we can make really great decisions together? And I've really enjoyed
being at this sort of intersection of engineering and applied stats in support of business decision
making. It's been a great role for me, which is why I've stuck around for so long.
Okay, and then there's a whole bunch of other uses of applied stats and related
techniques around Netflix, and much like you can go to jobs.bowing.com, you can go to jobs.netflix.com
and see what we have available. We are still hiring, admittedly at a much reduced rate,
but there are still some jobs that we're looking to fill. Okay, I want to sort of switch gears and
talk a little bit about some personal observations, and it's sort of motivated by the fact that I seem
to spend a lot of time providing some mentorship and having career combos with different folks,
and this is sort of the highlight of themes that seem to come up again and again. And I really want
to emphasize, right, your mileage may vary, right? Everyone's journey is going to look very different,
and maybe you can take some lessons from what I've experienced, maybe not, that's okay.
So first, the future is super uncertain, and this is particularly true right now, right? And I just
want to acknowledge this is a really rough moment on the hiring market, and so maybe if we think
like statisticians, we just say that like our predictive uncertainty on the future is much
higher right now, but it's always high, it's just a little bit higher right now.
It's taken me like a long time to get to the position I'm in, because I took so many detours
along the way, but what I want to emphasize is that that slow route, that exploration of different
opportunities, of different environments, different ways of framing problems, actually has a lot of
advantages. Every stop I've made along the way has made me a lot better at my current job,
though I also admit it can be frustrating at times, and I feel like if I move across the Pacific
one more time, it might do me in. So especially now, like focus on the journey versus like trying
to get to a particular destination as fast as you can. And of course, there's more than one way is
to get to a destination. I wouldn't have planned out a whole lot of different ways to get to a
destination. And of course, there's more than one way is to get to a destination. I wouldn't have
planned out this route if I knew I wanted to be like a data science experimentation manager
at Netflix, I would not have picked the route I took. And at times, I've clearly not even known
where I was going. But I really want to say that I think that's okay. As long as you're learning a
lot at every stop, you're sort of increasing the number of ways you can solve problems,
you're increasing your future value. And I've also found a lot of value in like being open to
paths I never envisioned for myself, I was so directly focused on an academic career for so
long. But even then, I'd take the odd call from a hedge fund from other places to learn a little
bit about what was out there. So to try on that that jacket, see how it fits, see if that's something
I could see myself doing. And I really want to stress, and this is something I learned way too
late, the Academy and even the tech sector, they have no monopolies on interesting people and
problems. There are great people and great problems everywhere. You just got to seek them out.
So this is a book that's really helped me understand my own path. It's called Range,
Why Generalists Triumph in a Specialized World. And as we think about the uncertainty, especially
in the tech sector right now, that like mindful ability to adapt to different situations to figure
out how to leverage your skill set in different ways, I think is just about the most important
skill that you can have right now. So one question I get asked a lot is how to successfully transition
from like an academic mindset to a private sector mindset. And Shannon sort of touched on some of
these points as well. And the big warning here is like you should acknowledge quite openly that
your graduate education has not prepared you for life outside of a university, right? And that's
okay. And what I encourage you to think about is the skill set you've acquired in your university
life, be that undergraduate or graduate. For me, this is the tool set of applied statistics and
the ability to grapple with complex data and think about uncertainty. And in your graduate work,
you've used that toolkit to optimize a particular loss or utility function here like writing a
dissertation and writing some papers and passing some qual exams and things like that.
But these can be completely decoupled, right? Your toolkit exists and has value
outside of that particular utility function. So what's important is to understand that your
utility function can be adapted, sorry, your toolkit can be adapted to optimize different
utility functions. And as you venture out into the real world, as you switch careers, as you try out
new industries, think in terms of a portable toolkit and then a new loss function. And your
job when you start in a new environment is to really figure out what that loss function looks
like so you can correctly optimize it using your toolkit. So if you come into an applied
industry setting and try to write research papers, that's not going to go well. But if you come in
and say, okay, I have this toolkit of applied stats and data analysis, let me figure out how
to use that to solve the first order problems faced by this company. Then you're kind of
recognizing that that loss function has changes and adapting your behavior accordingly.
So I'll leave you with this slide here, which is like the toolkit and this braided river,
right? Because there is a lot of uncertainty right now, there's a lot of people moving around
between jobs, really focus on the applicability of your toolkit and think about different ways
of achieving the goals that you have in your career, along with being open to exploring
goals that you didn't know that you had. Think in terms of shorter timelines, like don't think
I'm going to take this job, I'm going to be at this company for 25 years and I'm going to retire.
Think in terms of what do I need to learn over the next two years so I can set myself up for the job
that I really want. So be really open to positions that are maybe not your ideal.
Yes, the tech sector has had pretty massive layoffs, but like 60% of them have been from
four companies headquartered in San Francisco and Seattle. There's a whole lot of smaller
companies all around the company that are hiring like crazy, that are doing wonderful things,
that will provide you with an amazing opportunity. And from there, maybe you decide that's the path
you want, or maybe in 18, 24 months when the economy is doing a bit better, you use that to
jump to something else. And that's always super hard. And then two more final comments. First,
job hunting is a numbers game. It is a pure numbers game. From the other side,
from the hiring perspective, hiring is also a numbers game. So pump up your number, right?
Apply to everything that looks relevant, connect with recruiters on LinkedIn, leverage every
network you have, particularly alumni networks, which are great. And last, join optimization is
really hard. So think about what's essential to you and what's nice to have and make that essential
list shorter and just focus on that. Okay, that's all I got. And I will hand it back to our moderator.
Thanks, Martin. So let me share a bit about myself and what I do. And then we can get into Q&A.
I'll try to keep it as short as I can. I don't have slides, but let me just talk a bit about
myself. So I am originally from Sri Lanka. I did my undergrad there in industrial statistics.
And then I worked for two years in a financial research company, after which I moved to the US
and I got my PhD in statistics at Penn State. A really fun experience I had at Penn State was
for two years, I worked in the statistical consulting center. And so this gave me a really
great experience, you know, seeing a lot of different problems in designing experiments,
helping people analyze data. And that experience, I found that really enjoyable. And so while I was
at Penn State, I did two internships, first with Lubrizol, and then second with Microsoft.
And so that was the year before I graduated. And I really enjoyed, you know, both my internships.
With Microsoft, I didn't pick this team, but somehow how it happens with both
internships, as well as like fresh out of school opportunities, you respond to a very general
job post. And then your CV is picked up by teams who, you know, find you a suitable candidate for
a role they have. So I never really picked the team at Microsoft. They essentially picked me,
but it was a good pairing. So I work in the experimentation platform. That is the same team
that is the same team I interned on. Yeah, I don't have to explain what experimentation platform
is, thanks to Martin. And so I interned there and then got a return offer and joined full time in
2020. So kind of a typical day in my role as a data scientist on the experimentation platform is
one, we help teams across Microsoft run their experiments. And this, you know, can be challenging
because we have some teams who are very advanced and mature in their journey of experimentation,
and other teams who are just starting off. So we have to solve a lot of different
types of problems. So I work with Power BI, a relatively, maybe a relatively new team to
experimentation. And so I help them, you know, with their design of experiments with understanding
what metrics they need to include, and then interpreting results as well. And I also
do quite a bit of work within my team to help us understand how users are leveraging our product.
So basically, I help with running experiments for the experimentation platform,
and also for our business reporting, like what are some of the important metrics? Should we
rethink some of the metrics that we use for ourselves? Helping with, you know, some of the
data engineering or data pipeline work, and things like that. So those are the two main things. And
then in addition to that, we have some educational outreach that happens where we run classes for
teams across Microsoft. So, you know, I will volunteer for those kind of opportunities as
well. So that's kind of what I do at Microsoft. To talk a bit about hiring. So my team sits within
AI platform. And we have had, as I said, we have these general job posts for new high, fresh out of
grad school, as well as sorry, fresh out of school, as well as for interns. And
what we've seen in the recent past is these can be very general. And even in the interview phase,
you can have a loop interview with people from various different teams. This is so that, you know,
say you have a very strong competency in a certain field, but maybe the post that you
responded to, you know, is not the perfect match, but the team thinks, okay, you would do really
well in another team. And this kind of is a way to make sure that you don't have to keep interviewing
for different teams within the same org. One thing to note, we are having a hiring freeze right now.
So there might not be any open opportunities within AI platform at this time. But you should,
you know, keep looking for open opportunities. I know that there are other teams within Microsoft
hiring. So I do have an interview prep guide from Microsoft that I'd like to share. I'm
not sure if I can put it in the chat. So let me just quickly share my screen here.
Okay. Can everyone see my screen?
Yep.
Okay. So yeah, if you can, if you just search for this online, you should be able to find it.
So this gives some background about the team itself. And then about the interview process,
typically, there are one to two phone screens, and then either an in-person or virtual interview loop.
In more recent times, I've seen more of this. I've not really seen any in-person interviews.
The virtual interview loop will include about four to five people. And it'll be a mix of technical
and non-technical skills. And, I mean, you are not expected to show mastery in everything.
You should show competency in each area and then mastery in some. So in addition, so when talking
about non-technical skills, when interviewing, we focus on Microsoft competencies. So these are the
competencies, adaptability, collaboration, customer focus, drive for results, influencing for impact
and judgment. And so each, say, in a loop interview, each person will have a competency
that that interviewer is supposed to assess you on. And so that will motivate these non-technical
questions. And for the technical questions, you can expect, you know, to some of these topics.
Of course, depending on the interviewer, this will change, because depending on where they're
coming from. But, yeah, one thing that I have seen is that, you know, there's a lot of people
but, yeah, one thing that I have seen is sometimes, for example, with a coding question,
you are given the option of which language you want to use. And I have encountered this where,
you know, I've posed a question to someone and said, you know, use any language that you feel
comfortable. But they pick Python, although their main competency is R. And, you know, and then
they're not as, you know, familiar with Python being maybe from a strong stats background.
And I remember in this situation, at the end, she said, like, oh, I wish I had used
R. You know, I didn't want to, I thought that in industry, you know, Python is used more,
something like that. So when you are given a choice, or you can even ask, can I use this language?
And for these questions, we have a specific tool where you can actually write in that language and
you can compile it, etc. So that is one. The second thing, if you put something on your CV,
you should be able to have an in-depth conversation on that. So that is another thing
that I have seen as a pitfall. So there are some tips here in, you know, some tips for interviewing
that might be helpful. Asking questions is really important because it also,
it helps you kind of grasp more about what is being asked. It also helps
the interviewer give a sense of what it's like to collaborate with you. So you can almost think of
it as a collaboration. At Microsoft, you know, when it comes to evaluating
your performance, we look at your own personal impact, how you influence the success of others,
and how you leverage the success of others in your work. So collaboration is really important.
So also, again, I'm not sure, I don't think I have, you know, I can use the chat to share this,
but you can go to, you can look for experimentation platform. This is the team that I'm on to get more
details of what we do, the type of problems we are interested in, etc. So in terms of the
job market right now, it is a difficult time in tech with a lot of uncertainty.
And I agree with what Martin said, you know, there are, so in big tech, we see a lot of,
this issue seems to be heightened in big tech, but there are other companies out there that are
recruiting. And so, so not to be focused, don't be too focused on
big tech. I mean, look for opportunities, and those opportunities will be more competitive
than earlier, but also look elsewhere, there are plenty of tech roles in non tech industries.
So that would be my advice. Also to those who are, to international students who are on visas,
this is also a difficult time. And you need to have conversations around the support that
whatever company you are interviewing on, the support that they can give you
to be able to live and work in the US. That's very important. That was almost like a given
with some of the big tech companies, but with the current situation, there are issues even there.
Even there. So with that, I'd like to, oops, sorry, let me
stop sharing. And let's look at the questions that have come in.
I can see that.
Okay, Martin, I can see that you've answered the questions posed to you.
There were several open. Okay, this one is, this question is from Laura. As a recent
stats PhD grad, I've had little luck landing interviews with a wide search of large and small
companies. I worry about the growing gap in my resume of unemployment after graduation.
Should I indeed be worried about this and broaden my search to positions that are much lower?
Example, analyst positions for recent BA graduates, or should I continue to search for
DSML statistician positions that align more with my education? Does anyone want to take this?
I will venture into this thorny, but important question. Nothing I say is going to be the
actual answer, but if you're struggling, broaden in some way, also have someone sort of look at
your resume and say, okay, I'm going to do this, I'm going to do this, I'm going to do this,
I'm going to do this, I'm going to do this, I'm going to do this, I'm going to do this,
if you're struggling, broaden in some way, also have someone sort of look at your CV and look at
your application materials and see if they can help you hone in there and if there's a way to
sort of help you stand out as a candidate, but in general, yeah, I would broaden and kind of the
axis along which you want to broaden might be up to you, it might be position, it might be location,
it might be industry. Benadir, if I may add to what Martin said,
just the broad index, being able to extend your requirements are very important, so location is
cool, and as you said earlier, it doesn't matter how you get in, just get in and then learn what
you need to take you where you want to be, so don't limit yourself to one specific area
or opportunity or title, but just come in, learn what you need and then move on later
if you feel like there's not working for you. That's it. Yeah, and I'll point to just also
that tech might not be hiring right now, but there are other industries that are,
so for example, Boeing just went through a bunch of layoffs two years ago and we're actually in
the position to hire, but they might not be the right positions, but yeah, so I guess
one thought is, yeah, in any industry there will be need for positions for data scientists,
even in the manufacturing sector as well, so just kind of broaden your
approach, I guess.
Following up on that, on the same question, so this person said that they had
little luck landing interviews, so to me it also suggests maybe you'd want to revisit
how you've written your CV. I would suggest reaching out to maybe friends who you have
in certain companies that you would want to work in and asking them to review your CV or even if
you have access to your career guidance from your university, still reaching out to them to get some
feedback on your CV. One more comment here. Another technique is to try to figure out who
the hiring manager is or who the recruiter is and just ping them on LinkedIn. Less so for the,
here's my CV, I want this job and more like, hey, I saw some interesting roles, would you be up for
a casual chat? And then it's just like the door just opens a tiny bit and then as Bernard said,
keep getting the door a little bit open and then walk into the company and then figure out
where you should be at that company and once you're in the door, it's a lot easier.
Yeah, I can share a success story like that where someone reached out to me
and said, you know, can I just talk to you? And I said, okay, we can have a chat and I realized
just looking, you know, talking to her and looking at her CV that she would be a very good fit
for my team and we were hiring at that time and so I wrote to my manager and I said,
I think this person will be a really good fit and so that really fast tracked the whole process.
So making those connections can be really helpful. Okay, so this next question is for Bernard.
Can you give us tips on how to approach the hiring and our interview process? What is the world's
Fargo current attitude in terms of the current situation with layoffs and hiring freezes?
All right, so I'll start with the last question. Our attitude is we are still always looking for
top quantitative skills out there. So we actually are still hiring, right? So I'd advise the
Dobroa to check out our quantitative, check out the Wells Fargo site, look for positions titled
quantitative analytics specialist or analytics specialist or anything with analytics consultant,
analytics in, will probably fall in your field, right? But we have postings, like I said, and then
those are just current positions going on and like I mentioned, around September you'll also
be looking out for the targeted program where we are looking for people that are soon to graduate.
That are soon to graduate. So it'll come out, it'll be quantitative analytics program,
fellows, and you should make sure if by then if you're still on the market, you should make sure
to throw your heart in. And like Martin said, I have a feeling that Martin and I, we've kind of
overlapped on some job interviews because the ideas that he's talking about are key, right?
Connect on LinkedIn, reach out to hiring managers, even if the hiring manager is not there,
you don't see a hiring manager. I think I'm already seeing LinkedIn invitations for the
panelists, I'm sure you all are. So it's a good idea to just connect, reach out, figure out, hey,
what positions are coming? What are things that I think and how do I need to prepare for some of
these specific positions that I'm seeing out there? And you'd be surprised how open people are to
sharing opportunities with you. And then, you know, key thing also, I think someone talked about GAP
would be just look at other positions and look at your resume because there's something, there
might be a disconnect between how you're presenting yourself and what the hiring managers are looking
for. I hope this helps. Thanks, Bernard. So Blanca has a question. Thanks a lot for the presentation.
I wonder, except for LinkedIn, could we get connected with presenters in other ways?
I'm a business intelligence engineer with five years of experience. I think I can be a good
match for a few positions I saw at Netflix and Boeing.
Well, there are many ways, but it looks like LinkedIn is probably your best bet, right?
So, I mean, I'm not sure that we can post our phone numbers and information here,
but LinkedIn is probably as safe as a good bet, a place to start, right?
I don't know about that. Yeah, plus one, LinkedIn is the way to find me.
Yeah, I agree with that.
Okay, so Johnny has a question. If we get laid off,
do we have to disclose this to our next employer when we interview?
I mean, I don't think any of us are from HR, so maybe you should take this answer with some
skepticism, but I would say no. In fact, when I hire, I'm always mindful to not ask candidates
about potential gaps on their CV, because there's a lot of personal reasons that could lead to an
interruption in work, family reasons, health reasons. You wanted to do a startup and it
bombed after three months reasons, and of course, layoffs. So, I don't think there's
any need to disclose, and I actually think it's a red flag if a potential employer starts poking
you about that. And finally, I looked at the numbers last night, it's like a quarter of a
million people in the tech industry have been laid off, so there's absolutely no shame. There's no
personal failure in being laid off at this time. Some of the brightest engineers in the world are
now looking for jobs, so there's no shame, and it's not something you need to disclose.
I agree with that. Completely agree, too. Just, I mean, we've all been through different, across
different journeys in our career, so I mean, if somebody's asking you, hey, why do you have this
gap? Like you said, it's a red flag for you. It's a red flag for you. Just show your skills and don't
worry about the other stuff. So, I think we addressed all the questions. So, if you
still have a question that you would want to pose to us, please go ahead. I think we still
have time to take more questions.
Okay, we have a question from Wesley.
How do you bring up the conversation around diverse hiring practices and what that looks
like in the company you're interviewing for?
Could a person, you know, highlight, expand a bit on, are they talking about, is the candidate
asking for information on diverse hiring practices? Like you're going for a job, you're going to apply
for a job, you're talking about your particular kind AC and they aim to be asking about diversity.
Is that what Wesley is asking?
Wesley, do you mind adding a bit more detail here? Or do you want to, or do you mean within
the interview kind of asking what are your diverse hiring practices within the interview?
I guess I'll say a few things about what, I guess for, in terms of diversity at Boeing,
we specifically go out to, you know, the associations like Black Engineers, we go to
Society of Women Engineers. We kind of have a goal of hiring from those communities. So
from Boeing's perspective, I think like those would be good avenues to, you know,
participate in those activities and then you can reach kind of the right hiring recruiting team
there. So I guess, so that's from a kind of hiring perspective, like we are definitely looking very
aggressively at diversity and increasing diversity at Boeing. And I will say like up front, like most
of my team, I think my team is, you know, about 20, 30 people and we have like two other women,
right? I am surrounded by men, but we are really hoping to make changes there. And I think I've
seen quite a few changes throughout the years as well. I will say that in this environment as a
female in an engineering corporation, it's surprising that I don't feel flighted or, you know,
in any way like treated differently because of my gender, for example. So I guess like I would say
from what I've seen at Boeing, we've tried to work on this aspect and it's like a very,
very important aspect, at least to the Boeing Company. I'm sure like it is true for
mostly other big companies as well. So Wesley added in some clarification.
So basically to ask if the work, if the team that they will be working on is diverse.
So how I would ask this is maybe say like diversity and inclusion is really important for me.
And what does your team do specifically, you know, for this or to support this?
And I can speak a bit about Microsoft. When I first interned on my team in 2019, there were about
five or six women in a team of maybe 30 to 40 data scientists. But in the last,
just the last few years, we've had a lot more diversity, you know, gender of different
ethnicities and diversity and inclusion is a core priority. It is part of, we are assessed on it.
So just as we have to set goals for what work we will do, you know,
that is considered work too. So we have to set goals for ourselves for diversity and inclusion.
And there are opportunities to get involved more if you want to. So for example, I work on this
speaker series team that does various talks around culture and highlight different communities based
on like different heritage months and things like that. So it really depends on you how,
to what extent you want to do that and get involved. But it is a core requirement for everyone.
Okay. Wendy asks, Martin, did you have anything to add or? Okay. Wendy asks,
what in your experience improves one's chances of having high retention value?
Well, I think Martin wants to speak.
I just, I don't quite understand what's meant by high retention value.
So could we get some clarification there?
I think it's probably to avoid getting layoffs.
I mean, so I guess, I mean, I think, again, it's been said is
layoffs. I mean, different, I don't know, maybe different companies handle it differently,
but it's not, they usually don't say we're laying off like people necessarily because
they are low performance, right? It's really a cost-cutting initiative. So, you know,
the business would decide we have to scale down our activity in this particular line of business.
And so we cannot afford to keep everybody, right? So it could affect anybody, right? So some,
I don't know, some companies might say we're laying off low performance, but you know,
I think there are different ways. So it's not, it's hard to say I'm going to avoid layoff.
If you want to say, how do you want to add value, be viewed as a high performer, high contributor?
I mean, again, it's been said is you come in, you have your, you come in with your quantitative
skills, but you want to, it's really about you, how much you want to dedicate yourself to learning
the business. And you always find that you can add value in certain ways because your skills don't
go away. You can obviously have to keep refreshing them, but it's really how much you are able to
show that you're adding value. And it could be in a technical area, applying, you know, some unknown
technical skills, some rarely used technical skills to solve a problem that's widely known
or finding a problem that's obscure, but solving it in a way that makes a big impact, right? And
obviously I think Shannon talked about just how you interact with people. You know, so you,
you can be very good at what you do, but if you don't get along with anybody, it's going to be
also hard for you to show that, for someone to say, I really need to have this person on my team.
So it's a mix, it's a mix. But again, layoffs, again, from what I've seen, it's not really about
laying off, you know, removing low performance. It's really about a business need to scale down in
an area. Right, so I'll let others speak out too. Yeah, I agree. I think, I think it's, I think of
it as more this role is not needed anymore, rather than it's not really, you know, this person. It's
more the role when it comes to these kind of restructuring changes that end up with people
getting laid off. And kind of, you know, also echoing what Bernard said. So there are two
things that I think, you know, in order to be successful in a company, once you enter in,
of course, one, you have to have impact, like you have to do the work, but also you have to be
mindful of how you bring visibility to the work that you do. Because sometimes, you know, you might
be doing a lot of work, but if you are not showcasing that well, it could get lost. So,
and a lot of the decision, decisions that are made, you know, for promotions and things like that,
that doesn't happen at your manager's level, you know, he can nominate you, but it happens at a
higher level. So kind of getting visibility that I think is important.
Shannon, Martin, do either of you want to add to that? Okay.
Let's go to the next one from Ekaterina. Hi, I would like to become a data analyst,
but I have no experience. Will it be enough to complete a course from Google for a certificate
in data analytics for an entry-level role? I worked in sales and have economic education.
Please give some tips how to start.
Ekaterina, it's a great question. I don't think it's impossible.
Most industry positions don't really care how you've acquired the skills. They just want to see
your ability to demonstrate those skills. That said, like there's a lot of markers that tend
to be correlated with being able to do those skills, and you will be at a slight disadvantage
there. How you can kind of overcome that is to like lean heavily into some of these networking
activities. I once hired an engineer who has no college training, but he just was performed
amazingly well in our interviews. And the reason we interviewed him is that he specifically tagged
me on LinkedIn and then found my email and sent me a long list of reasons why we should interview
him. And I was like, okay, I like this guy's enthusiasm. Let's give him a shot. And he's great.
So there's always ways, but sometimes they will take more effort.
Okay, let's get to the next question. So this question is for Wells Fargo.
Will many research experience draw your attention for an analyst research role?
Yes, I mean, definitely. So again, we talked about how you can demonstrate what you know
in an interview. Well, if you actually have these on your resume and you've kind of highlighted the
problems you saw, the techniques that you used on your resume, that actually gives you a leg up
going into the interview. So definitely more ability to demonstrate your knowledge and your
skills. Even before you get to an interview is attractive, right? So it doesn't hurt you at all.
Okay. And so we have one more question from Wesley. Is there any need for Bayesian statistics,
knowledge and skills in current experimentation platform job tasks? That's for me and for Martin.
I can go first. So our platform heavily relies on frequentist statistics, but we do have,
maybe you might not require Bayesian statistics like in your day-to-day work, but there are
certain research projects where we look at, you know, incorporating new tools into our platform
where we have data scientists who will use these tools. Martin?
I am personally a huge fan of Bayesian inference and part because I think the outputs are more
interpretable to humans who don't have degrees in statistics. So I keep trying to hire folks who
know a lot of Bayesian statistics to work on our platform and we are slowly drifting in a Bayesian
direction. It's going to take us a little while to get there though.
Okay. Dabrina, I agree with Wesley's question. With the government, there are clear direct and
fixed avenues for hiring disabled, hiring veterans, et cetera. But question for the panel,
in the industry commercial sector, should you bring up the conversation about diverse hiring
practices early in the process, or is it only worth focusing on bring forth this later in the
process? Suppose that you only know a little bit of that specific companies and I think that it
got cut off after that. So I think it probably doesn't hurt.
Yeah.
It probably doesn't hurt to bring whatever background up. It probably isn't something that
you might want to only focus on, but it wouldn't hurt to just bring it up. If someone is a veteran,
for sure, you should mention it. Why not? It's not going to hurt you.
Yeah, and do some research into if the company does have some pipeline of hiring people,
because I know that Microsoft, I think, has certain avenues for veterans to join.
Okay. I think we answered all the questions, and we are at time.
And so thank you, everyone, for posing your questions. Thank you for the panelists
for sharing your thoughts. And is there any survey or feedback? I'm asking this question
from the organizers. Yes, there will be a survey that everyone will have access to at the end of
the webinar. Thank you so much for all of our panelists to come out today and talk to everyone.
Thank you.
Bye.